Jeff Ross for those that don't know and
they would they do know he's a really
good friend of mine he's the roast
Master General and I think he was uh
instrumental in starting your career
absolutely huge I'm going back to
theaters now myself doing them and I'm
seeing the sound guys and the and the
stage managers that I met 12 13 11 14
years ago with Jeff who took me out on
the road I think I was only doing 10
minute sets or 15 minute sets you know
Jeff was my opening act really yeah
yeah wow so this is like the Darwin
theory of of Comedy we're right here
yeah yeah this is beautiful how he
pranked me when I opened for him uh I I
was in some big theater and um I guess
there was a musical on the off nights
happening and all the instruments from
the orchestra were behind the curtain
and Howie and his Buddy Rich pulled up a
giant six foot gong to the back of the
curtain every I got big laugh they'd hit
the gong so only I'd hear it behind the
curtain on the laugh and it looked like
he had a like he had Tourettes right he
was you would see him he'd do a a
punchline and then he'd do that the
audience couldn't hear it because they
were roaring with laughter but he would
just do he would just twitch at the end
but Jeff you hired him to write for the
roast the big roasts right on Comedy
Central Tony when I met Tony this is a
long time ago now uh he was a a door guy
at the comedy store right Tony yep and
uh he was a little skinny broke door guy
broke and uh but he would he was like
the joke the roast Whisperer he would he
would he would tell me little roast
jokes and I mean how did it spark
initially do you remember exactly I it's
it's very interesting I was I was
smoking pot with Jeff Scott the old
piano player behind uh The Comedy Store
at we were actually at the top of the
parking lot belly room staircase and I
said to him I go you see that guy he's
like yeah Jeff Ross I go
I'm going to work with him very very
soon when he finds yeah I go when he
finds out how good I am at making fun of
people we're going to have to work
together and then it was actually
literally about an hour later there was
an opportunity you were on the front
patio and no one you weren't being
bothered by anybody and I said Jeff I'm
Tony you've seen me with the Baris Brody
overdrive playing air guitar or whatever
and uh I just want to let you know that
uh if you ever need any um extra roast
jokes for anything whatsoever I'm super
super down and really really good at it
and I think we could really really help
each other out something to that effect
wow and I was like yes Tony I really
admired your air
guitar but no I remember you told me
that yeah Tony we W up writing on uh
comedy centrals the burn and a lot of
the roast and side projects and we
became uh writing cohorts all the time
and eventually uh we took our show on
the road up to Canada we did a a
nationwide tour of America and of
Canada